behind the scenes Democrats are modeling
the best leader for the party who could
win against former president Donald
Trump in 2024 amongst the names of
possible contenders former late First
Lady Michelle Obama who's at who's 59
years old and with her it Factor could
emerge as a top candidate however she
has repeatedly denied any interest in
seeking office some high-level Democrats
are rallying to President Biden's
re-election not because they think it's
the best interest of the country to have
an 82 year old start a second term but
because they fear the potential
alternative the nomination of Kamala
Harris and election Donald Trump other
possible candidates include those who
previously won the Democratic
presidential nomination such as Hillary
Clinton John Kerry Al Gore but they
failed to address the concerns of some
voters who want a younger president as
Clinton 75 Kerry 79 Gore
74. she's 59. she's a very very
formidable candidate 100 huge formidable
huge she's huge no I don't
is there any indication any what that
she's even interested in running it
doesn't I don't I'm not I don't think
it's I don't think there's anything
that's uh that she's given no indication
that she's gonna be running I don't
think she's running I think it's I think
there's some hope for her to run I think
if you're looking if you're a Democrat
and you're looking at Biden you're like
all right buddy God keep it moving
sleepy Joe you might this is sort of
Wishful Thinking sort of re-emergence or
Renaissance of Obama and her husband
will be in the white house I don't see
it I've seen nothing of it she keeps
putting getting pulled in in the polls
for the top five topic I just there's
nothing she announced at him and she was
up running against would you vote for
her I'm until I see a candidate that I
think is a better candidate than Ron
DeSantis I'm in the DeSantis and I
respect you for that we talked about
that even over Michelle Obama bro like
Adam I think there could be a moment
because well think about it we're not
we're the audience Pat you everybody in
here we're not stupid but Joe Biden is
not in charge of anything the real
people the real Democrats that are part
of the democratic party Obama's in there
with Hillary in them I'm telling you
right now if they get scared to a point
where they're like hey guys this cat's
not gonna win maybe um newsom's not
really the guy we're gonna have to pull
the trigger and say listen Michelle I we
love you we know you don't want to do it
because you're selling out Arenas just
talking about God knows what we need you
to run why would she say no they need
her if your husband's like yo the party
needs you we can make our change we can
make our policies make our things I
think she'd say yes 100 but by the way
first first let's ask this question the
first question is would you put her at
the top of the list on the left that's
the most formidable if if she ran 100 is
she above Newsome think like a Democrat
not that you like or don't like 100
likability her last name you agree I
think I think at the top you have
Michelle and Newsome and if you have
want me to handicap between the two I
think it's 60 40 and she's 16 okay 40 on
the top two and I don't care about
anybody else and stop talking about
Kamala Harris the big money and the DNC
want her to go away yesterday perfect so
yeah yeah so so every time he stumbles
you can see the story she told about
conservatives concerns yeah she's almost
when she does that off of diarrhea I
have to go to the restroom but but let
me hear you talk about space because
space shuttle space space is so vast
that's why they call it space here's a
question yeah here's a question if
Michelle Obama did you agree that she is
the most formidable on the left I don't
what do you think is uh
formidable yeah
I think
formidable yes you still have to put
Biden on the list because he's the
incumbent president do I think he's a
formidable in general no but but
currently fine but then I would put
Gavin Newsom up there head on Michelle
uh yes Michelle's not anywhere even on
my top 10 list me personally really you
might be like I'm crazy that's nuts and
she's given no indication why though
she's done nothing
this is not an indication question this
is a question of she's African-American
she's the wife of Barack Obama she's not
really a first lady she was seen as a
partner yes of Barack Obama she is
strong on the left they love her Oprah
Hollywood music Beyonce there's a lot of
different things there right she's a
dancer okay so so you're not saying
whether she's formidable Mark you just
don't think she's gonna run I'm just the
you know there's nothing that's
basically motivating me to give two
shits about Michelle Obama right now
yeah but that's not the question no I
get it I wouldn't go to Michelle Obama
rally I don't know what she stands for
she's never let anything you're gonna
you're gonna he's the wife of a
president in my eyes that's it do you
realize like even the AV people didn't
go to Biden's rally they left
the audio visual people that were
working the mic they just left because
they said no one's going to be here yeah
okay let's play this game with Michelle
Obama why would Michelle Obama if you're
sitting there with her you're at her
house she trusts you you're somebody
with her and a Barack you're having
dinner you and four other people that
she trusts and you say Michelle why do
you not want to run she's going to say
what
I just want to be a mother I enjoy being
a wife I enjoy our life
is good money's good we are living
low-key we get to do whatever we want to
do I'm enjoying my years with my husband
we got plenty of you know years left in
us and what we want to do I just don't
want to do it okay so then you have to
go through the concerns my schedule so
now the other person's got to sell on
and say what if we could put a team
together around you where you can still
do a lot of things you want to do
but we go out there and do this and we
do a one-term thing right now because
the only reason we do a one term is
because Trump's probably not going to
run four years from now do one term
let's pick a VP let's give the VP to
whoever else anyways the conversation
about how to sell her to run what she
doesn't have to give up the life do you
sell The Supporting Cast or do you sell
the history or do you sell America
Democrats need you what do you sell what
do you sell to Michelle for her to run I
don't think you ever grew up somebody
like that and say America needs you do
us a favor I think you sell her on cause
precedent and Legacy you'll be the first
female president you will be you will be
able to set a chart for a lot of the
things that you believed in and you were
working on do you remember when you
cried the afternoon the inauguration
because you you said you felt like you
were giving up your the the momentum
that you had on the causes Michelle you
can put all the back on the front burner
you're only 59 years old and and by the
way America needs you to lead this cause
I sell her on cause and Legacy I think
there's gonna be one problem Pat it's
it's you know the whole thing they're
gonna they're not gonna find one picture
of her on the internet where she's
pregnant here we go and that's going to
be one of the problems I'll put that
that's a challenge for anybody that's
watching you cannot find one photo of
Michelle Obama pregnant online and I'm
telling you right now that's gonna be a
problem where they're gonna go wait a
minute where are you pregnant that's
where are you gonna go with this I was
just gonna say people are gonna be like
dude show me one honey I know you love
these types of stories
out there I'm gonna address the question
even if even if there's there's no
pictures here's a question for you yeah
objectively
we're playing fantasy football elect the
president
you have to be the Democrat captain
sell me on selling her to do it
um I'm taking you as my quarterback
telling me to have uh Michelle do it
you're talking to Michelle you're
selling Michelle on doing it run
Michelle I would say let's listen uh
first of all the way that it's looking
the guy that's in charge right now we're
gonna lose we're gonna lose everything
with this guy you're gonna be the savior
of the party look what your husband did
look at the look at your legacy look at
your family we need you because the way
that it's looking Guess who's coming
back Trump I'm telling you and if you
don't like Trump trump light is going to
be the Santa's we need you your husband
needs you like I think you guys got it
all wrong I don't think so and I'll tell
you why
there's nothing to sell her on
either she wants to do it or she doesn't
that's my opinion you don't think her
husband has anything hear me out you
don't think Barack Obama's gonna be a
conversation between her and Obama
and you know hey you're 6'10 you're a
big guy you should be of NBA power
forward you should work it's like yeah I
don't I don't I don't want to play
basketball you're not gonna sell
somebody to want to do something how
many sales guys we have upstairs that
work value tell me shout out to them
yeah hey if you do this you can make
this amount of money I promise it's the
life of your dreams yeah I don't really
want to make cold calls there's nothing
that shows me that she has the heart and
the fierceness to want to do this no one
has to sell her on this if she she needs
to sell herself or need she needs to
look in the mirror or have a
conversation with her husband was the
two-term president and there's nothing
that I'm seeing that she wants this
Trump
he [__] wants this like him or not he
wants this DeSantis is heading that
direction where you know behind closed
doors he's like I can do this okay even
Biden had to kind of get pushed into it
he didn't want to run against Hillary
2016. now he's there was nothing to sell
this time around he kind of got sold
this time there's nothing to sell
Michelle Obama she either wants it or
she doesn't and in my mind she does not
want this job okay she don't want this
smoke she doesn't want to Adam but the
reason she is who she is is because the
Democratic party's husband is made her
you would never have known who she was
this is going to be okay you don't think
he has no say in this like hey we need
we need you all this is going to be very
controversial and I hate to do this on
International women's day what okay
Obama's the man he's the husband he's
the president okay she's a first lady
that's it Melania hottest first lady
ever I don't need her [__] run in the
country okay that's it that's the extent
of what I think of Michelle Obama
I disagree with that I challenge you to
go back and look at the origins of
Melania origins of Michelle Obama
Michelle Obama was not some model of
hottie Communications major at College
she's a lawyer she was formidable they
were working together in Chicago one
thing she's got cause on her heart and
that's why I say cause precedent Legacy
that's how I sell it you're absolutely
right that she's not just some Slovenian
model that showed up for to be a third
wife very hot okay I got that choose a
hypothetical example I know exactly I I
got that part no doubt she they met in
law school I get it you either want this
fight or you don't want this fight
there's nothing that I see about
Michelle Obama that she wants this at
all listen I would bring Ryan Gosling
and I would have him stand in front of
her and say what do you want what do you
want yeah and then we would watch the
notebook and we would say let's go build
that white house for you Michelle you're
a percentage guy and I value exactly
because you're not you're gonna go down
Vinnie conspiracy Lane that's not a
conspiracy find I'll find the photo of
her pregnant what are your chances not
her electabilities high no doubt that
she wants to do this she wants to that
no it that she would do this less than
100 okay so you're at less than one I'm
less than one percent all right so
you're in Sussex Camp No I said she
don't want this no no it's not it's not
she doesn't want this listen there are
honestly there are certain jobs
that you don't get to choose if you want
to do it or not
it's it's a calling it's a the
conversation is like okay when you get a
call say somebody becomes a president
they say Adam
your your worth 70 million bucks it's 20
years from now you're 60 years old okay
Adam I need you to come in and be the
secretary or whatever or I need you to
do this we need your help on this part
here and it's a guy that you respect a
lot and he's done a lot for you and
you're like dude I'm married I got kids
listen I'm telling you right now I need
you
this is not a call to ask you I'm
telling you I need you
so I'm not recruiting you I'm telling
you
you're the right guy for this job and I
know you like the country club lifestyle
I know you've been chilling I know you
like to get on that boat I know you like
doing all this stuff totally get it bro
but America is bigger than you and I and
I need you right now so when can I get
you to come to DC for us to have this
conversation together that's the phone
call you would get from me if I was the
guy there so if the people she respect
the conversation is
we kind of need you right now here's
what's going on there's a difference
when you're called versus a job to do
this is not a job this is a calling so
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]